lässt sich der klimawandel
beziehungsweise die folgen davon die
erderwärmung noch irgendwie aufhalten
oder vielleicht stoppen wenn wir
technische hilfsmittel einsetzen
das ist eine frage die stellt sich nicht
nur jetzt während der klimakonferenz in
madrid sondern schon länger und viele
ingenieure zerbrechen sich den kopf und
die kommen auf ideen die sind so ein
bisschen ja manchmal ganz praktisch
nachvollziehbar andere klingen eher wie
auf so einem james bond film oder aus
dem komischen science fiction movie
geoengineering nennt sich diese ganze
idee und eine frau beschäftigt sich
schon länger damit dass das sek strifler
vom potsdam institut für
klimafolgenforschung die ist jetzt in
berlin zugeschaltet hallo frau
schaeffler was ist denn so die
merkwürdigste abgefahrenste idee in
puncto klimafolgen auf halt hilfsmittel
die sie bisher zugehört haben die
abgefahrenste idee war wahrscheinlich
die idee große spiegel im all zu
installieren die das sonnenlicht
reflektieren sollen und so die erde
kühlen ja die haben wir auch gerade
schon im tief verfassen weil die fanden
wir auch so hübsch es gibt aber auch
ideen ist relativ realistisch mit den
beschäftigen sie sich bevor wir aber da
tiefer eintauchen und über die risiken
und nebenwirkungen sprechen hat uns ja
auch ein spiel mal zusammengefasst was
da so an ideen durch die
wissenschaftliche welt geistert was wenn
die menschheit die reduzierung der
treibhausgase nicht in den griff bekommt
und die erderwärmung weiter
voranschreitet
dann könnte climate engineering zum
einsatz kommen technik im ganz großen
stil um das klima zu beeinflussen
eine idee sonnenspiegel im weltraum
sie könnten dafür sorgen dass ein teil
der sonnenenergie reflektiert wird und
die atmosphäre erst gar nicht erreicht
auch das verteilen kleinster partikel
weit oben in der atmosphäre könnte
helfen die sonnenstrahlen dort möglichst
früh zu reflektieren neue dünne wolken
die künstlich aus meerwasser gewonnen
würden könnten die sonne am himmel
abschirmen die dicke wolken die wärme
unter sich aufstauen sollten dagegen
absichtlich ausgedünnt werden auch
könnten niederschlagsmengen und orte
gezielt beeinflusst werden die
erdoberfläche sollten wir deutlich
aufhellen um hier unten möglichst wenig
wärme aufzunehmen künstlich blubbernde
meere werden hellblau die
wasseroberfläche würde die sonne besser
reflektieren und sich weniger erwärmen
kunst bäume sollen co2 aufnehmen und
nebenbei schatten spenden
auch für dächer und versiegelte flächen
sollten weißtöne der neue trend sein und
das ganze co2 würde massenweise zum
beispiel unter die erde verfrachtet oder
in gedüngten ozeanen mit algenteppiche
neutralisiert doch so kommen beim
climate engineering auch kritische
fragen auf wer bezahlt diesen kraftakt
und können selbst die größten solche
anstrengungen den klimawandel stark
genug beeinflussen
die antwort offen ja viele ideen und
viele fragen zu diesem thema jessica
striefler vom potsdam institut für
klimafolgenforschung kennt sich da
bestens aus bevor wir uns mal genauer
mit diesen einzelnen maßnahmen
beschäftigen man ganz grundsätzlich
gefragt können wir mit diesen maßnahmen
dem klimawandel aufhalten auch wenn wir
jetzt die klimaziele 2050 die ja gerade
wieder verkündet wurden dass man dann
klimaneutral sind vielleicht doch nicht
erreichen
ja da muss man zunächst mal
unterscheiden climate engineering oder
geo engineering ist ja so ein
oberbegriff der zwei ganz verschiedene
methoden umfasst und zwar wird der
klimawandel verursacht durch eine
erhöhte treibhausgaskonzentration in der
atmosphäre die dazu führt dass mehr
energie aus der sonneneinstrahlung auf
der erde verbleibt und deswegen hat man
jetzt um den klimawandel aufzuhalten
oder zumindest zu verringern zwei hebel
an denen man ansetzen kann
das eine ist die verringerung der
treibhausgas konzentration ganz direkt
und das andere ist die verringerung der
sonneneinstrahlung auf die erde und das
sind eben zwei zwei sehr verschiedene
maßnahmen die ganz unterschiedlich
wirken und können wir mit den
tatsächlich dann bewirken dass wir hier
unten nicht gekocht werden man kann mit
beiden methoden die globale
mitteltemperatur absenken
die entnahme von co2 aus der atmosphäre
senkt eben die treibhausgaskonzentration
also die konzentration von co2 und das
wird ganz direkt im klimawandel entgegen
also dass das behebt sozusagen die
ursache wohingegen die reflexe so die
reflektion von sonneneinstrahlung
sozusagen eine andere art von eingriff
in das klima ist dass zwar der
temperaturerhöhung entgegenwirkt aber
das klima ist ja nicht nur temperatur
das ist eben auch niederschlag und auch
das wird davon beeinflusst und aber das
wird eben nicht genau der effekt des
menschengemachten klimawandels damit
aufgehoben
also beide wirken der temperaturerhöhung
entgegen aber beide machen auch
verschiedene dinge mit dem klima das
klingt jetzt ein bisschen so als wenn
wir jetzt doch nicht mehr so viel co2
sparen müssen also alle können weiter
fleisch essen suv fahren weil wir haben
mehr als hightech und können das co2
irgendwie anders loswerden ist das so
das so ist es eben gerade nicht
die co2 und name wird zwar dem
klimawandel entgegen und da werden auch
eine ganze reihe von maßnahmen
diskutiert aber diese maßnahmen haben
alle auch irgendwelche nebenwirkungen
und die sind auch alle offene auf die
eine oder andere art und weise
beschränkt also wir können nicht einfach
so weitermachen wie bisher und das co2
daneben aus der atmosphäre rausholen
das funktioniert nicht die maßnahmen
sind sind entweder beschränkt oder sehr
teuer das heißt das macht auch
ökonomisch überhaupt keinen sinn da
jetzt munter weiter zu emittieren und
das dann hinterher wieder rauszuholen
wofür gibt es dann die maßnahme
überhaupt was soll das dann in der die
sind eben dafür da dass wir die menge an
co2 die wir nicht verhindern können dass
wir dass wir das aufheben also der
hintergrund ist wenn wir wirklich den
den die temperaturerhöhung stoppen
wollen dann müssen wir mit unseren
emissionen auf null und das wird ja auch
festgehalten in den klimazielen der eu
diskutiert dass deutschland diskutiert
dass das ist diese die klimaneutralität
über die gesprochen wird also wirklich 0
und jetzt wird es aber sehr schwierig
die emissionen komplett zu vermeiden
also wir werden schon sehr viel
reduzieren können
gerade zum beispiel durch den
kohleausstieg können wir können wir sehr
viel reduzieren aber wir müssen eben aus
allen fossilen kraftstoffen aussteigen
und wir müssten auch die emissionen in
der industrie die passieren also da
werden in den chemischen prozessen co2
freie gerade zum beispiel bei der
zementproduktion es gibt noch andere
treibhausgase wie stickoxide die in der
landwirtschaft bei der düngung zum
beispiel frei werden
das muss alles komplett auf null und das
werden wir sehen wahrscheinlich nicht
schaffen die auf null zu reduzieren
sondern wir können sie vielleicht um 90
oder 95 prozent reduzieren und der rest
der dann noch übrig bleibt den müssen
wir irgendwie ausgleichen und dafür sind
diese maßnahmen gedacht also kein ein
hilfsmittel um uns irgendwie noch
schnell zu retten wenn es nicht klappt
sondern eigentlich eher so national
beiwerk genau genau also dieses alle
hilfsmittel das gibt es leider einfach
nicht also wir kommen nicht drum rum wir
müssen unsere emissionen massiv
reduzieren
verdammt jetzt hatten wir gedacht wir
hätten kurz die lösung gefunden werden
wir uns diese verschiedenen maßnahme
angucken sie haben gerade schon ganz
grob unterteilt einmal zu versuchen
sonneneinstrahlung ab zu deckeln also
das quasi nicht so viel wärme rauf kommt
das andere ist die idee co2 irgendwie zu
binden aber da gibt es ja ganz
verschiedene maßnahmen können sie
versuchen das ein bisschen einzuordnen
also welche maßnahmen gibt es da welche
ideen und welche sind realistisch das
versucht man gleich mal sollten aber
vielleicht erst mal so was gibt es da an
an ideen des co2 irgendwie ja sagt
kontrolle zu kriegen kann man das
einfach in so große behälter wo man oben
dann luftballons mit aufhören könnte
packen oder ist das nicht so einfach
ganz so einfach ist es leider nicht die
natur hat uns nur ziemlich einfache
maßnahme geschenkt das ist der baum der
baum oder die wälder zeigen bin sehr
viel co2 also das kennt ihr schon oder
büchern und kinder also wir könnten
wieder aufforsten
wenn wir mehr bäume pflanzen und mehr
wälder
dann würden die eben in ihrer
wachstumsphase co2 aus der atmosphäre
binden und wenn man den weiter nicht
wieder abreißt sondern stehen lässt dann
hat man die atmosphäre co2 entzogen
das ist die eine sehr einfache maßnahme
aber dann haben wir ja wieder dieses
blöde problem da braucht man flächen für
da kann man ja tolle vertreten aufbauen
oder sondern autos draufpacken das ist
ja vielleicht schwierig teilweise aber
auch dauert es ja länger gibt es da
nicht noch andere maßnahmen die
schneller gehen also genau das ist das
problem bei der aufforstung ist
tatsächlich der der hohe
flächenverbrauch das war auch das was
ich eingangs meinte mit die maßnahmen
sind alle irgendwie beschränkt also das
ist das eine es gibt dann auch sehr
technische maßnahmen bietet sogenannte
director capture verfahren daher kann
man sich erst hemd schafft verfahren hin
laut das länger am netz mit dem man
durch die gegend läuft nicht ganz man
kann sich dass er so vorstellen wie eine
art künstlichen baum der eben co2 aus
der atmosphäre fällt
der nachteil an der sache ist man hat
dann das co2 und muss dass noch irgendwo
speichern
also das ist nicht wie bei einem baum
dass es darum steht sondern man muss das
zum beispiel geologisch in der erde
verpressen
das geht der nach der anderen heraus
tatsächlich dann das kommt nach allem
was wir jetzt im moment wissen kommt das
nicht mehr aus aber das klingt nach sehr
weil etwas sehr energieaufwendige nicht
dann erst wieder gas sammeln muss und
dass wir da rein pressen dann sicher
wieder energie für oder genau das ist
auch der große nachteil an dieser
methode die ist ziemlich energie
intensiv und dadurch auch relativ teuer
also da haben wir zwar nicht unbedingt
so ne begrenzt
die beiden bei den wäldern mit der
fläche so eine direkte aber wir haben
sozusagen so eine indirekte begrenzung
dadurch dass die energie ja irgendwo
herkommen muss und die energie muss
natürlich auch wieder co2 neutral
produziert werden
also da ist die energie und und die
kosten sind da eher der begrenzende
faktor dabei ist sich das co2 zäpfchen
ein bisschen wieder selbst in den
schwanz
ich habe auch gelesen dass man auch co2
aus der luft filtern könnte und dann zu
kraftstoffen verarbeiten also das konnte
ich nicht so richtig vorstellen wie soll
das funktionieren
das ist grundsätzlich auch eine idee
also man kann zum beispiel aus also im
prinzip läuft einfach dieser
verbrennungsprozess umgekehrt ab wenn
ich fossile kraftstoffe also öl oder zum
beispiel erdgas auch verbrenner erdgas
ist ja methan also ch4 das verbrennt
nicht mit sauerstoff und der co2 draußen
und dabei wird energie frei jetzt kann
ich den prozess auch umgekehrt ablaufen
lassen indem ich energie reinstecken
kann ich aus co2 dann und wasserstoff
oder wasser kann ich dann wieder erdgas
machen also methan das funktioniert auch
das ist relativ energieaufwändig und das
problem bei der sache ist
das reduziert uns nicht hier die
konzentration von co2 in der atmosphäre
weil ich nehme zwar das co2 aus der
atmosphäre und machte einen treibstoff
draus aber wenn ich den wieder
verbrennen damit ihr das co2 wieder frei
also schnell perpetuum mobile nicht ganz
aber es geht immer hin und her
davon will genau das ist so die idee
dass man so eine art kreislaufwirtschaft
daraus macht aber die die konzentration
von co2 in der atmosphäre die wird man
dadurch nicht senken und das ganze ist
eben auch ziemlich energieintensiv eine
sache haben wir gerade video gesehen und
ganz kurz nur algenteppich das heißt
irgendwie die idee dass man das co2
nimmt und das eigen zu fressen gibt also
quasi eigene züchtet weil die ist ein
bisschen wie bäume im meer züchten oder
und genau also das kommt ein bisschen
auch an wie man das macht wenn man das
wenn man da die algen züchtet um dann
aus den algen wieder irgendwelche
kraftstoffe oder baustoffe oder und
futtermittel oder was auch immer
herzustellen dann hat man auch das
problem dass das co2 danach wieder frei
wird wenn man das jetzt irgendwie auf
dem offenen meer macht in der hoffnung
dass die algen dann irgendwann wenn sie
absterben absinken
dann würde darf vielleicht der
atmosphäre co2 entzogen werden aber da
macht hat man eben auch mit einem mit
dem sehr großen und wichtigen und
fragilen ökosysteme zu tun dass man da
eingreift also auch da sind sind die
risiken sind durchaus vorhanden ich
wollte gerade sagen es gibt auch immer
diese bilder von riesigen alten
teppichen der in bochum schwimmen und
drumherum ist irgendwie alles tot oder
ja genau die frage ist was macht man mit
dem ökosystem in dem man da einfach
riesigen züchtet und die zweite frage
ist wie viel von dem co2 wird
tatsächlich langfristig gebunden also wo
gehen diese alten eigentlich hin singen
die wirklich bis auf den meeresboden ab
ist da das co2 wirklich langfristig
gebunden also da kommt wirklich darauf
an wie wie das jetzt gemeint ist mit den
eigenen so ich schau mal in die
kommentare was unsere zuschauer so sagen
da haben meine kollegen schon mal
fleißig gesammelt hier in unserem
geteilten dokument
der mensch sollte nicht gott spielen
meint oliver linz fällt mir gerade mal
ein gut ich glaub das ding ist er
gelaufen oder also wir haben schon in
die natur eingegriffen
mal gucken wie wir wieder rauskommen aus
der nummer ich schätze mal dass dieser
kommentar sei er auf diese auf diese
reflektion von sonnenstrahlen bezieht
und weniger auf diese diese co2 und name
techniken weil die reben wirklich dem
entgegenwirken was wir gerade machen das
ist ja das problem wir greifen schon
sehr massiv gerade in das klima ein
und jetzt jetzt geht es darum diese
auswirkung irgendwie zu verhindern hier
ist eine spannende frage auf youtube von
andreas gibt es einen einzigen fall bei
dem der mensch ein selbst verursachtes
problem durch weiteres herum fingern und
noch mehr technik nicht noch
exponentiell verschlimmbessert hat das
große beispiel dass mir da einfallen
würde ist das ozonloch das haben wir
tatsächlich durch die fck so haben wir
da unsere ozonschicht geschädigt und
dann gab es das material abkommen über
dem festgelegt wurde global dass die
emissionen dieser gase jetzt begrenzt
wird und die wurden dann durch andere
gase oder durch andere mittel ersetzt
und tatsächlich erholt sich gerade die
ozonschicht wieder das heißt da haben
wir es tatsächlich hinbekommen da haben
es tatsächlich mal hinbekommen dass wir
ein internationales abkommen geschaffen
haben oder geschafft haben das dann auch
wirklich das problem behoben hat also
jetzt gibt es natürlich menschen hier
die das ganze alles komplett infrage
stellen und ihm einen gibt es alles gar
nicht die möchte ich ganz kurz zum
beispiel auf den kanal unserer kollegen
von terrex schicken da gibt es so ein
paar schöne videos da könnt ihr euch mal
angucken warum das mit dem klimawandel
doch ziemlich real ist wenn wir uns
jetzt mal angucken was wir haben an
verschiedenen ideen also eine
wiederaufforstung also mehr bäume
pflanzen co2 binden in gestein zum
beispiel meer oder in alten unterirdisch
lagern zu kraftstoffen verarbeiten
sonnensegel aufspannen welche von diesen
möglichkeiten dies da so gibt es sind
tatsächlich realisierbar oder sind
tatsächlich schon in der mache und und
werden gerade umgesetzt also
wiederaufforstung ist natürlich
realisierbar aber auch dass dieser
stelle capture verfahren also diese
künstlichen bäume auch da gibt es schon
gibts schon demonstrationsanlagen die
das eben gerade machen
auch die geologische speicherung von co2
ist möglich da gab es auch schon eine
ganze reihe von demonstrationsanlagen es
gibt auch eine reihe größerer projekte
die noch laufen in den usa zum beispiel
oder in kanada also da gibt es eine
reihe von möglichkeiten die tatsächlich
machbar sind bei den sonnensegeln wäre
ich der erste tisch aus technologischer
sicht aber auch weil die risiken da
einfach sehr groß sind dann machen wir
in anderen eingriff in das klima und die
frage ist natürlich auch wie sollen wir
uns da eigentlich international darauf
einigen wie viel genauer davon gemacht
wird wenn man sich anguckt wie die
international sowie schwierig die
internationalen klimaverhandlungen sind
dann kann man sich bei solchen methoden
schon vorstellen dass das sehr schwierig
wird dann internationales abkommen zu
finden genau das wollte ich eigentlich
auch fragen wie soll das gelingen ist
das noch ein mann ist das etwas was aber
auch einzelne staaten vielleicht so für
sich immer und umsetzen können ich meine
ob ich jetzt bei mir in der landschaft
künstliche co2 fangen bäume oft oder
nicht ist ja meinem nachbarland erstmal
egal oder
genau das ist im nachbarland vermutlich
egal oder beziehungsweise findet das
nachbarland vielleicht sogar gut weil
das eben genau der ursache des
klimawandels entgegenwirkt und die
folgen trägt dann eben eher derjenige
oder das land das diese methode einsetzt
aber es gibt ja auch methoden die setzt
sich beim 1 1 zum beispiel haben wir
gerade gesehen auch man lässt wolken
entweder entstehen oder man löst sie auf
diese ideen gibt es und dadurch greift
man ja in das klima ein was oder in das
wetter ein was nicht lokal begrenzt ist
gibt es da nicht auch das risiko dass es
dann richtig ärger geben könnte also zum
beispiel zweimal china macht irgendwas
um bei sich wolken zu binden und in
indien jetzt keinen konsum mehr genau
das ist das problem das ich dass ich
gerade meinte und man macht einen
anderen eingriff in das klima der eben
nicht nur die temperatur verändert
sondern auch das lokale klima verändert
und die niederschläge verändern kann zum
beispiel in den indischen monsun und das
ist eben nicht was was jetzt genau dem
dem klimawandel den wir gerade
verursachen durch unsere
treibhausgasemissionen entgegenwirkt
sondern dass es eben eine andere art von
von klimawandel und wenn das ein land
einfach eigenmächtig macht und das
auswirkung hat auf ein anderes land das
da unter umständen davon schäden
davonträgt natürlich kann das große
schwierigkeiten geben und da müsste man
eben also sowas einsetzen zu können
bräuchte man ja ein internationales
abkommen und da habe ich doch stark
bezweifelt dass wir da etwas hinbekommen
gibt es denn jetzt maßnahmen wo sie
sagen würden okay das funktioniert auch
ohne so ein gemeinsames abkommen ohne
dass es jemand kontrolliert weil das
kann jeder für sich machen wir halt kann
oder möchte das sind eben genau diese
maßnahmen die co2 aus der atmosphäre
wieder zurückholen so was wie
aufforstung oder david erkämpfte das ist
aber eine sache haben sie auch gleich
mehrfach gesagt die kosten teilweise
richtig viel geld die länder die aber am
meisten unter dem klimawandel leiden das
merken wir auch gerade jetzt in madrid
die beschweren sich ziemlich dass sie
eigentlich die rechnung bezahlen sollen
und die industriellen staaten haben das
ganze verursacht diese länder haben doch
am ehesten noch die probleme das
überhaupt zu bezahlen oder das werden
wahrscheinlich auch nicht die länder die
das jetzt unbedingt machen würden also
zumindest nicht so wie data capture was
relativ teuer sind wieder auf wachstum
ist ja nicht so teuer dass können
natürlich andere länder auch machen
gerade sowie data capture das würde man
jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt in den
regierungs ländern aufbürden also dass
es eben was was die industrieländer
leisten können und auch eben leisten
müssten das ist dass sie diese
technologie erstmal entwickeln und auch
einsetzen aber trotzdem müsste man ja
die regierungen wahrscheinlich der
industriestaaten überzeugen dass das
einer maßnahme ist die jetzt einzusetzen
wäre die kostet geld oder kann man noch
geld verdienen also gerade so was wie
director capture man hat ja da kein
produkt das einzige produkt das man
dabei hat ist eben die senkung der
treibhausgas konzentration das heißt man
kann damit nur geld verdient wenn man
dafür geld bekommt also wenn man wenn
co2 preis hätte also hat sie teilweise
auch schon im deutschen oder im
europäischen emissionshandel
also wenn man sozusagen für die emission
von co2 geld bezahlen muss und für das
rückholen von co2 geld bekommt dann
würde sich sowas lohn und das ist
wahrscheinlich auch die die einzige
möglichkeit mit der mit dem man sowas
anreizen kann ansonsten
haben sie da nicht hoffnung einfach nur
aus gut goodwill und weil man sonst das
klima vergessen kann wird nicht reichen
da wird man zumindest solche solche
maßnahmen ich mache vielleicht würde man
so was die wiederaufforstung machen
einfach weil das auch irgendwelche
anderen positiven effekte hat also jetzt
einfach für die sozusagen als als
naherholungs wald oder auch für
biodiversität also da gibt es auch
andere gründe warum man das machen
könnte so eine seine technischen sachen
wie der igbce denke ich würde mir nur
machen wenn man einfach geld bekommen
gucken zum schluss noch mal in den
kommentare was ich da so gesammelt hat
auf youtube ist einiges los
enyo hat schreibt wenn
umwelttechnologien profitabel sind haben
alle ein interesse daran das stimmt
wahrscheinlich aber paar grill ist auch
er nicht so guter hoffnung der
lobbyismus ist viel zu stark
wahrscheinlich ist gemeint der
lobbyismus der industrien die noch mit
fossilen energien heizen
sebastian ist für eine tradition hin zu
einer pflanzlichen ernährung das wäre
ein relativ einfacher und effektiver
schritt weiß ja jeder tun kann wo das
ist natürlich dass mit dem co2 verzicht
und wohl gleich darunter ist es allein
lotter kommentare die sich hier
aneinander reihen meint es geht dauernd
nur um profit und wirtschaftswachstum
das ist das größte problem würden sich
dem anschließen frau stehen naja das
also ich würde sagen das größte problem
sind eben die co2-emissionen die ja
teilweise dadurch entstehen dass wir
eben energie also strom brauchen die
teilweise dadurch entstehen dass wir uns
irgendwie fortbewegen wollen
das werden wir nicht irgendwie von jetzt
auf nachher oder auch nicht
mittelfristig alles irgendwie auf null
reduzieren könnten also wir müssen schon
gucken dass wir von diesen also dass wir
sozusagen bisschen diesen
technologischen wandel schaffen dass wir
eben unseren strom nicht mehr über kohle
kraftwerke erzeugen sondern über
erneuerbare dass wir unser
transportsystem so umbauen dass wir eben
nicht mehr mit dem verbrennungsmotor
fahren sondern mit elektromobilität oder
mit dem fahrrad oder mit eben auch
grundsätzlich mehr öffentlichen stadt
dass jeder sein eigenes auto hat auch
bei der ernährung natürlich umstieg auf
ganz sicher ernährung
hilft also diese ganzen sachen werden
wir machen müssen unabhängig vom vom
wirtschaftssystem
also ich glaube nicht dass das so zu
sagen dass da der schlüssel liegt
sondern dass wir wirklich unsere unsere
technologien umstellen müssen und
obendrein vielleicht noch changing
weiter ausbauen und weiterentwickeln das
machen sie unter anderem gestreifter vom
potsdam institut für
klimafolgenforschung vielen dank dass
ihr heute abend bei uns waren uns das
noch mal erklärt haben
und vielen dank für eure ganzen
kommentare und fragen wir sehen uns
wieder aber am nächsten donnerstag mit
dem nächsten live stream in diesem sinne
sage ich danke fürs zuschauen und
tschüss und wenn ihr mehr zum thema
wissen wollt dann guck doch mal hier
rein da haben wir einen stream gemacht
mit harald lesch über das klimapaket
klamauk mit ziemlich guten trend von ihm
oder guck doch mal hier in den stream
rein da geht es um die frage ob wir
vielleicht keine kinder mehr kriegen
sollten um das klima zu schonen und
außerdem natürlich immer licon
kommentaren abonnieren
[Musik]